Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so the actor the
plays any Thawne confirm he's coming back
to the show so we got a break this down.
He didn't say exactly which episode he's gonna
come back for but there couple theories about
what can be going on and why they're bringing
him back now.
So there's a new round of the flash ring giveaway
that starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video winners
are usually announced at the end be sure to
click that bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss anything.
So many things going on here.
So we'll talk about who he might be how they
might use them in the future and why they're
bringing him back now.
So, they always bring the big characters back.
But number five I think the biggest reason
they're bringing him back it just sort of
a way to get the fans and trying to fix the
character just a little bit because he started
out in season one, when they first teased
them and they explain what his name was everyone's
like oh my got what's what's going on here.
He was one of those things where they take
a name from a really big character like the
biggest character from the flash is villains
gallery and then sort of pair that with the
characters you never heard of it with a Backstory
that's unfamiliar so any Thawne is not somebody
from the comics but they hadn't explained
that the reverse flash was going to be the
big villain eobard Thawne.
So this was just meant to show you that he
can go in any different direction.
Sort of like storm clouds on the horizon like
whose substance can be happening with his
character, but what ended up happening is
kind of unfortunate because he ended up getting
sidelined in this melodrama plot where he
and Barry were competing for Iris's affections.
I don't think the dudes that were watching
the show were very happy about this and I
don't think that the Iris fans that were watching
were happy about it either because she didn't
really have anything to do during season one
other than be the object of affection like
she was the prize that was won by either Barry
or Eddie, so rewind back to the first half
of the season.
They do provide some context for Iris's character
how she grew up with Barry how she was so
important to him that she really didn't exist
without Barry or without Eddie's storyline,
so I think everybody was just really unsatisfied
with the way that it up happening, so they
wanted to fix that in the back half of the
season so they completely changed what their
original plans were for the characters.
So number four what was that original Eddie
Thawne plan like over.
They originally going to do with the character
before they decided to kill them off because
Andrew Kreisberg the show runner said that
originally they had something totally different
in mind they were going to kill them, but
when they did use him get sucked up into the
singularity with the talisman on.
So he got to be the hero, but that is are
like tease that something really big was going
to be happening later on in season two like
who there very clearly setting something up
comic book rules.
If there's nobody that he's not dead.
So originally allowed people had theories
that Eddie Thawne would be the season to villain
because his character had Hunter Solomon's
back story from the comics with a Thawne name,
so people like who may be he's going to be
the zoom of season two he'll be like the big
bad because Barry still his girlfriend.
So in explaining it.
That way you kinda see the problem with that
like they didn't want to turn Iris into the
object of affection in that way.
So I think they just pivoted their plans.
But originally I think their plan was is to
make Eddie more of a season two villain person
in the way that arrow did the same thing with
Slade Wilson in the first two seasons.
So if you didn't watch arrow what happened
in the first season is that you meet Slade
Wilson and anybody that reads comics is like
oh my God this is deathstroke and he's friends
with all of her on the island what's going
on here.
This is so crazy where the gonna take this
season two that plays out.
He becomes the deathstroke character in a
became one of the best seasons of arrow ever
do because the same people that make arrow
started making the flash it sounded like they
were sort of repeating that paradigm.
But then about halfway through decided to
pivoted and double down on the Jay Garrick
storyline set that up and make him more of
a thing in season two during season two they
took actual Hunter Solomon and sort of pair
that with the Jay Garrick storyline and is
much as that made people upset like long time,
comic book readers are like oh my God, you're
telling is that Jay Garrick is evil.
So before the big twist at the end where they
reveal it is actually secretly Hunter Solomon.
This been pretending to be Jay Garrick people
really upset, even long time flash comic book
writer Mark Wade who the flash TV show borrows
a lot of stuff from was really upset for the
explain.
The twist he was this big thing that people
get upset at TV shows all the time.
So it was kind of funny watching you know
like old, comic book writer shake their fists
and stuff, so I actually think that the show
chose the lesser of two evils the of the chose
to not recycle the deathstroke arc from arrow,
but in doing so he kind of threw themselves
into like this big Jay Garrick twist that
played out like relatively okay could've been
a lot better, but number three.
The other logic problem.
I get so many questions about this if any
Thawne died at the end of season one the reverse
flash of that moment was erased from existence.
How did he come back alive and well during
season two of this gets into time travel rules
one of the problems with Syfy TV shows is
that sometimes you have an actor or a character
like Ora storyline.
The just has so much chemistry and works so
well you want to find a way to capitalize
on that later on, but if there dead you have
to find a way to explain how they came back.
So the beauty of the reverse flash is that
he is basically the smartest person in this
universe.
Maybe next to Jesse quick but the way they
tease Jesse quick is that she's smarter than
Harrison wells from earth two, so one of my
favorite lines from him during season one
is when he actually says I'm a genius where
I come from imagine what that makes me here.
So because of the way he exists in flash Canon
is like the biggest villain that Barry as
ever had ever will have is that he sort of
the Baltimore in has whore cruxes plans in
case he dies so because he's a time traveler.
Doctor Who style is a lot of different versions
of him that overlap traveling through time
trying to get rid of Barry Allen or bring
some evil plan to fruition.
So even just on earth one in our universe
there multiple versions of eobard Thawne.
They're all aware of each other like he understands
time travel like no one else when you messed
with time travel.
We learned during season two the time wraiths
will come for you.
The reverse flash is one of the few people
that knows how to keep off their radar.
So he's able to time travel in a way that
the other flashes are.
But the simplest explanation for how eobard
Thawne is still alive after Eddie killed himself
is one because of flashpoint, now but to because
of a speed force protective bubble like a
speed force whore cruxes.
So even if you haven't read the comics earlier
this season.
Jay Garrick explained that the speed force
is sort of a nexus of space time it exists
out of normal space time so if a younger version
of the reverse flash is traveling back through
the speed force.
When older reverse flash gets killed in the
speed force protects that younger version
from the consequences of Eddie's death.
So as of season two that's really the only
way that Eddie can still be dead in the reverse
flash on earth one can still be alive because
number two you know which version of Eddie
is this going to be.
So like I said flashpoint happen this season.
It could choose to bring back Eddie V of flashpoint,
but I feel like that creates more problems
than it's worth.
And you have to explain why he's not around
all the time on earth one, the easier explanation
is that is earth two Eddie we learned during
season two is alive and well.
Based on Barry's phone there still friends.
We have no idea how different he is the just
teased his name like oh Barry talks to him
on a regular basis he's on his speed dial
so clearly there friends he's doing well this
is great.
So this season.
They will be going back to earth to eventually
so that be my first boat is that when they
go back to earth two just find a way for Eddie
to show up, you guys can let me know which
version of Eddie you want them to use.
I just feel like the Jesse quick is a really
good example of why multi-verse characters
are the best way to explain why people aren't
around.
So Jesse quick is the flash of earth two they
have all the same types of problems that they
have on earth one.
Maybe not savitar level problems, but they
still have villains running amok so team flash
on earth two is the exact same thing, the
team flash on earth one does she's very, very
busy, so she can just come over and hang out
all the time in the other thing about earth
two or three you know multi-verse characters
is part of the fun is that you get to learn
how their life is different and what's different
about them or they a villain on a different
earth, we can learn about all the adventures
that they had that we didn't get to see because
it was in a different universe, so number
one though what about turning Eddie into a
villain or a speedster in the future season
like cobalt blue style doing something really
crazy.
Some big twist with him the original plot
line of season one to season two like I said
sounded like they wanted to do that with him
use him as more of the Hunter Solomon zoom
character turn that twist from the comics
into a big thing, so in the comics.
Hunter Solomon is a police detective that
works with the Wally West character inside
the Central city Police Department gorilla
Grodd attacks the city his spine is broken
so he can't walk anymore and Wally refuses
to go back in time to change it.
So in his grief, Hunter Solomon tries to use
the cosmic treadmill to fix it himself gets
into an accident and it gives him powers,
turning him into the zoom character.
So that's comic books zoom TV zoom was like
a completely separate thing, so I don't think
the gonna do that but I did it is totally
possible they could pick one of the other
lesser speedsters to make Eddie Thawne some
future villain Orson a small twist but I feel
like if they did that it would be like the
rival he be around for a couple episodes,
it would be like a really small thing.
He wouldn't be the main villain.
Let me know if they bring Eddie back and turn
them into a villain in the future season which
character do you want him to be was can happen
next is that unless they drop some footage
him and to be doing a Legion trailer video
is basically X-Men Breaking Bad for the most
powerful X-Men character ever.
It's a new TV show that's going to be on FX
networks in the United States, it's gonna
simulcast internationally on Fox channels.
So I'll explain when I post a trailer video
that can be a Thursday show going forward.
So I almost forgot.
Congratulations to the new reverse flash ring
giveaway winner Kieran Owens be sure to private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
I will be doing giveaways for the Legion TV
show so I'll explain when I post that later
today while you wait for that you can click
here to watch the trailer for the next episode
of the flash and you can click here for my
Star Wars episode eight people rain.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you guys tonight!